poi tutto bene tutto a posto
da ieri sera che ancora che se n'è
andata una rassegna di cinema d'autore
hanno primeggiato questo film iraniano a
cristo di ritornare michael molto molto
emozionante per le sincere una
bancarella che vendeva queste borsine
realizzate dai bambini del nepal ho
preso un paio e il 2 per cento del
ricavato va in beneficenza i minatori
del congo fair questione non ci sono
perché poi arriva tutta la massa di
august aurelio andiamo più a fare un
giro in barca a vela genere ha poi
andiamo a fare il giro della corsica in
bici e poi forse andiamo anche in belize
in cambogia no adesso vuoi puoi sempre
fare organizzarci però ti dico già che
stai scrivendo il libro della mia vita
sono attimi o presa e cosa parla
praticamente parla di non so come guerra
è un po difficile spiegare quindi se
prima e meglio che quando esce poi ci
regala due copie
vuoi darmi un passaggio in macchina no
guarda per scelta io giro solo con mezzi
ecologici
da allora ci becchiamo in giro magari
dai buone vacanze